Chief Justice John Roberts sworn in to
preside over only the third impeachment
trial in America's history do you
solemnly swear that in all things a
pertaining to the trial of the
impeachment of Donald John Trump
President of the United States now
pending you will do impartial justice
according to the Constitution and laws
so help you god these are the senators
who will act as jurors for some is a
forced break from the 20/20 campaign
trail the dry ceremony is in sharp
contrast to explosive new evidence which
casts president Trump's actions as quite
simply illegal Lev panis is a central
figure in the alleged effort to pressure
Ukraine into smearing Joe Biden's 2020
candidacy he says Trump knew everything
what do you think is the main inaccuracy
or the main lie that's being told that
you feel like you can correct that the
president didn't know what was going on
president Trump knew exactly what was
going on he was aware of all my
movements
Donald Trump has given panache the
treatment he often reserves for those
who say things he doesn't like I don't
know don't know what he's about don't
know where he comes from know nothing
about him I can only tell you this thing
is a big house it's a big house
in response left Parnassus lawyer
tweeted this video of his client with
Trump he says at mar-a-lago para nós
himself says everytime Trump denies
knowing him he'll release a photograph
of them together Republican senators are
naturally reluctant for his claims to be
included in the trial if they are afraid
of the truth
the American people have seen the
allegations and their allegations we
need to see more evidence that was would
be contained in the documentation so
there this is just another avoiding of
the facts and the truth on their part
more damning evidence suggests that al
stood US ambassador to Ukraine Murray
Ivanovich may have been put under
surveillance by Trump's allies this is
being taken seriously enough for
Ukraine's police to open an
investigation to top it off a
nonpartisan congressional watchdog says
the White House hold on military aid to
Ukraine violated federal law all this
would be enough to sink your average
president but Donald Trump has
successfully created an alternate
narrative but this is a witch-hunt no
Republican has publicly disagreed it's
not clear what it would actually take
for the GOP to start breaking ranks
Amanda Walker Sky News Washington